I'm Lisa Schröder, I'm a qualified nurse. What I
'm most challenged by at the moment about the
pandemic is
that we have to wear mouthguards
simply to protect ourselves, especially to protect
our
clients. You communicate so much with clients through facial expressions
and a little
smile makes so much  and unfortunately that is
no longer possible at the
moment my message would be that everyone adheres to
all exit restrictions and
other specifications that everyone
adheres to them and really only buys the most necessary
things that no hamster purchases are
made and think mainly
of the other people who are
at  belong to the risk group most
i see myself changing
clothes afterwards meeting my friends going
out drinking cocktails
visiting festivals and going
to discos my fellow human beings would
help me if they stayed at home
together against corona